on va retrouver pascal thibaux à berlin
bonjour pascal alors moscou vient
revient donc sur sa position pourtant
très ferme d'imposer un règlement en
roubles de ses livraisons de gaz aux
européens
effectivement ça ressemble à priori
après ce qu'on a pu comprendre du coup
de fil hier soir entre olaf scholz et
l'admirent poutine à un rétropédalage en
quelque sorte de la russie puisque
vladimir poutine avec l'arrêt d'après le
communiqué de la chancellerie à berlin
que les occidentaux les européens
pourraient commence continué à payer
leurs livraisons de gaz en euro et en
dollar ch seule différence cela se
ferait à destination de la banque du
fournisseur à savoir la banque gazprom
qui n'est pas frappé par des sanctions
contrairement à la banque centrale russe
olaf schulze n'a pas approuvé ce
mécanisme et il a demandé des détails
par écrit et il a réitéré la position
des européens et du g7 exprimer la lddhi
de refuser de modification des contrats
voilà un petit peu la situation pas très
clair ce matin on en saura peut-être
plus dans la journée puisque aujourd'hui
vladimir poutine à moscou rencontrera la
banque centrale et les responsables de
gazprom le fournisseur de gaz des pays
européens
pascal bonjour cette annonce de vladimir
poutine intervient précisément au moment
où plusieurs pays européens dont
l'allemagne ont annoncé un plan
d'urgence pour l'approvisionnement en
gaz
oui effectivement il ça a été le cas où
c'est le cas dorénavant depuis hier en
allemagne après l annonce faite par le
ministre de l'économie et du climat le
vert robert avec ce plan d'urgence
comprend plusieurs étapes on a déclenché
pour l'instant là la première étape qui
n'a pas de conséquence concrète on
surveille simplement plus étroitement
les livraisons les réserves en énergies
c'est seulement dans des stades
ultérieurs qu'il faudrait prendre des
décisions sur des restrictions et
savoirs et prio priori triops donc
afficher des priorités pour savoir qui
doit encore obtenir suffisamment
d'énergie
ça serait dans ce cas là dans le pire
des cas au détriment surtout des
industries les plus consommatrices par
exemple comme là chimie alors que le
gouvernement réitère le fait qu'il n'y a
pas de danger pour les particuliers
néanmoins le ministre recommande aux
allemands et aux industriels plus
largement et bien d'essayer de faire des
économies chaque kilowatt qui n'est pas
utilisée qui n'est pas dépensé et bien
c'est un peu ça réduit aujourd'hui un
petit peu la facture énergétique pour
l'allemagne pascal thibaux depuis berlin
pour france 24 merci beaucoup pascal